les civils ukrainien prise au piège de
la guerre aidé par une solidarité
inédite qui prend de l'ampleur sur
internet sur ce site de location de
logements saisonniers les réservations
en ukraine se multiplient céline aisée
et parisienne elle a réservé pour 3
nuits et payer 128 euros un appartement
à kiev qu elle n'occupera pas une façon
originale de faire un don je cherchais
des annonces qui semblait venir de
particuliers plutôt que de
professionnels et trois heures après
j'ai eu un retour en france est d'une
jeune femme irina un échange qui n'a
rien d'habituel entre autres ses clients
pas de discussion sur les modalités de
la location mais des messages
bienveillants et solidaire je voulais
vous dire à quel point votre soutien me
touche nous sommes une famille avec une
petite fille de 5 mois et mon mari est
français irina est pour le moment
toujours en ukraine à dnipro avant la
guerre elle louait régulièrement cet
appartement à kiev aujourd'hui inoccupés
sans doute pour de longs mois les
réservations affichent pourtant
virtuellement complet pour les
prochaines semaines une solidarité qui
riina et son compagnon français n'avait
pas imaginé on n'a plus d'activité
professionnelle puisque toute la société
et les filmant en veille ça nous permet
d'avoir un revenu pouvoir venir
à minima
ressent ici que le monde entier nous
soutient une étrangère comprennent ce
qui se passe compatissent comme ça
spontanément à notre situation en
ukraine nous sommes très touchés de
l'aide de chacun pour soutenir cet élan
de solidarité la plateforme airbnb a
suspendu les frais de commission
marielle terrine harel a réservé une
chambre à kharkiv pour 40 euros la nuit
bouleversés par les images de
bombardements qu'elle voyait à la
télévision
je me dis que sur une journée si on peut
décrocher faire décrocher un sourire à
quelqu'un même si c'est dur une seconde
ça a l'air assure un petit peu plus de
soixante et une nuitée ont été réservées
par tout en ukraine 1 million 800 mille
euros ont ainsi déjà été versée
directement à d autres ukrainiens